[Music]
that were bombing all the roads were
blocked all the transport went on hold
Russia's illegal Invasion blocked
Ukraine's key transport routes it left
Ukraine unable to import the good sets
people needed all get its essential
products to World Markets
via Road Rail and inland waterways this
is the story of an unprecedented joint
effort to open alternative transport
routes for Ukraine
the problem we are trying to solve is no
way Regional or european but global
completely new sometimes crazy sounding
Solutions
securing transport routes for everything
from grain to fuel and humanitarian Aid
authorities and businesses in EU member
states Ukraine and the Republic of
Moldova are working hand in hand to
ensure Ukraine can import what it needs
we have been importing big quantities of
fuel for for the supply of Ukraine
and export its goods to the world is
foreign
[Music]
Ty lanes are simplifying border
crossings getting Goods where they need
to go faster
this is
the war has brought Ukraine and the
European Union closer together than ever
before and these new connections between
us are here to stay we have to do that
in flower Greene
thank you